eine wirklich bahnbrechende neue
erkenntnis unser heimisches schwarzes
loch hat einen jet ein unsichtbarer
schwerkraft kam direkt im zentrum
unserer milchstraße
das supermassereiche schwarze und auch
italien a stern doch woher kommt seine
starke radio im mission bislang hatte
die fachwelt einen jet fern ein doch
jetzt konnten erdrückende hinweise auf
ein bisher unerkannte materie strom
aufgespürt werden klicks um science im
future geht es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen ein gigantisches
massemonster mit einer 4 millionenfach
größeren masse als die sonne die rede
ist vom schwarzen loch namen sagittarius
aussterben mitten im zentrum unserer
milchstraße und diese masse ist auf
engstem raum zusammen gepackt ein
schwarzes loch also dass nur 26 tausend
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist als
super massereiches schwarzes loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße prägt
sagittarius sternen die bewegung aller
gaswolken sterne und sterne ströme grund
dafür sei eine gewaltige schwerkraft
noch eine frage raubt der fachwelt den
schlaf wie ist die starke radio
emotionen unseres schwarzen lochs
begründet woher kommt sie zwei
verschiedene erklärungsmöglichkeiten
kommen in frage zum einen könnte es sich
um diffuse strahlung handeln die von dem
material abgegeben wird das den
ereignishorizont umkreis doch
tatsächlich wirkt immer mehr die zweite
erklärung möglichkeit ins visier der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
demnach könnte es sich nämlich um einen
bisher um erkannten jet handeln
eingerichtetes bündel starker
beschleunigt dass strahlung und teilchen
das problem der diffuse nebel aus heißem
gas streut die radiosignale von
sagittarius erstarkt genauere
beobachtung werden somit quasi unmöglich
doch jetzt mehren sich die hinweise auf
einen solchen verräterischen aus strom
laut einer aktuellen studie hat das
schwarze loch im zentrum der milchstraße
also tatsächlich doch einen aktiven jet
einen schwachen ins all hinaus
reichenden strom aus strahlung und
teilchen bisher hatte man das lange für
unmöglich gehalten was weiß man bisher
zu diesem verräterischen aus strom und
wie kann man sich die jets die unser
heimisches schwarzes loch produziert
vorstellen die spannende antworten auf
all diese fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei
klicks vom science and future
2020 gab es für die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die die
theoretischen grundlagen für sagittarius
stern entwickelt und entdeckt hatten
sogar den physik-nobelpreis mit dabei
war unter anderem auch der deutsche
wissenschaftler reinhard genc zusammen
mit anderen forschern dann hatte er sich
auf die jagd nach dem wohl
mysteriösesten objekt in der gesamten
milchstraße gemacht etwas mit sehr viel
masse dass sich in ihrem zentrum
versteckt mit hilfe von infrarot
teleskopen entdeckten die fachleute
sterne die im zentrum der milchstraße um
etwas zu kreisen schieben doch die
umlaufbahnen zeigten sich als sehr eng
einer der beobachteten sterne brauchte
lediglich 16 jahre für eine umrundung
des supermassereichen objektes das dort
vermutet wurde die bahnen wurden ganz
genau ausgemessen und so waren die
rückschlüsse auf die masse des objektes
im zentrum möglich 4 millionen
sonnenmassen geht man nach der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie kann es
sich um nichts anderes handeln als um
ein super massereiches schwarzes loch
doch klar ist direkt sehen können wir es
nicht und bisher gibt es auch noch keine
konkrete abbildung von sagittarius stern
dafür allerdings vom zentralen schwarzen
noch der galaxie m87 dem
zusammengeschalteten event horizon
teleskop war damit eine echte sensation
gelungen das erste schwarze noch
überhaupt dass man fotografieren konnte
für das event horizon teleskop wurden
acht radioteleskope überall auf der welt
verteilt zusammengeschaltet ihre
aufnahmen konnten so durch eine
interferenz technik zu einem gesamtbild
kombiniert werden die erreichte
auflösung entspricht dadurch einen
riesigen teleskop dessen antenne fast so
groß wie die erde ist die große
herausforderung bei der erforschung der
mysteriösen massemonster schwarze löcher
machen ihrem namen alle ehre sie
verschlingen zwar materie und licht doch
selbst leuchten sie nicht denn die
materie dichte in ihrem inneren ist so
groß dass nichts aus dem
gravitationsfeld entweichen kann nicht
einmal licht und so ist es mit optischen
teleskopen quasi unmöglich solche
massemonster aufzunehmen eine kleine
ausnahme gibt es an dieser stelle
vielleicht die sogenannte hawking
strahlung die bislang nur theoretisch
postuliert wurde sie ist allerdings wohl
sehr sehr schwach ein schwarzes loch zu
fotografieren ist also alles andere als
leicht zurück zu unserem heimischen
schwarzen loch im zentrum der
milchstraße
es war in der vergangenen zeit vor allem
durch strahlungs ausbrüche aufgefallen
im mai vor drei jahren 2009/10
beispielsweise hatte sagittarius
erstellen wird zweieinhalb stunden hell
im infraroten spektralbereich
aufgeleuchtet und zwar sehr intensiv
laut der fachwelt übertraf die identität
des ausbruchs die typische strahlung aus
dieser region um mehr als das
hundertfache
seitdem kommt es immer wieder zu
strahlungs ausbrüchen und
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zerbrechen sich bei ihrer suche nach
erklärungsmöglichkeiten den kopf fest
steht im vergleich verhält sich das
schwarze loch im herzen der milchstraße
eher ruhig doch das war wohl mal anders
forschende gehen davon aus dass sein
stern vor und zwei bis drei millionen
jahren eine gewaltige eruption
durchlebte diese könnte so gigantisch
gewesen sein dass dadurch sogar der
irdische nachthimmel und weit entfernte
extragalaktischen gasströme erhält
wurden einen großteil der strukturen im
galaktischen zentrum die heute
nachweisbar sind sind eine folge dieser
explosion die große frage aber die die
fachwelt immer noch vor ein rätsel
stellt gibt es aktive ausströmen
galaxien zentrum oder anders formuliert
ist das schwarze loch auch heute noch
aktiv genug um einen jet zu erzeugen
feststeht schwarze löcher bringen den
tod wenn ein stern in die nähe eines
schwarzen lochs gerät wird dieser durch
die enormen gezeitenkräfte
auseinandergerissen das schwarze loch
saugt es ohne erbarmen auf in der
fachsprache ist von einem sogenannten
teile des wachsen event die rede es
kommt zu sogenannten jets aus
energiereichen teilchen gas klumpen am
ereignishorizont und allen ausbrüchen
die eingesetzte materie sammelt sich
zuvor in der sogenannten
akkretionsscheibe des schwarzen lochs
eine schnell rotierende scheibe und
genau diese akkretionsscheibe skis
gigantische materie strahlen aus vielen
schwarzen löchern heraus senkrecht nach
oben und unten ins all und das sind die
sogenannten jets die man sich
tatsächlich vorstellen kann wie von ten
es handelt sich also um stehende
strahlen bündel aus schnellen teilchen
und strahlung die senkrecht zur galaxien
ebene stehen bei aktiven galaxienkernen
sind solche jets über millionen
lichtjahre hinweg sichtbar unser
heimisches schwarzes loch dagegen
scheint nicht über diese ausströme zu
verfügen so dachte man jedenfalls bisher
doch bereits in den vergangenen jahren
gab es immer mehr hinweise darauf dass
es eben doch so einen aus strom geben
könnte die daten von radio und röntgen
emission nahe des galaktischen zentrums
hatten die existenz eines jets
nahegelegt die spuren eines schwachen
kurzen aus stroms hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vor allem südlich der milchstraße neben
ausfindig gemacht doch gibt es auch
nördlich des galaktischen zentrums
indizien die für die existenz eines jets
sprechen ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt
daten mehrere teleskope des alma
observatorium in chile und des
hubble-weltraumteleskops analysiert und
die fachleute wurden fündig so spürten
sie unter anderem einige auffälligkeiten
auf dazu heißt es in der aktuellen
studie die alle aufnahmen zeigen eine
einzigartige lineare struktur die
inmitten der ansonsten komplizierten
bewegungen der angeregten molekularen
gase im galaktischen zentrum mit konkret
handelt es sich um einen schmalen
gasstrom der bis zu 6,5 lichtjahre vom
galaktischen zentrum entfernt
nachweisbar ist das konnte mit der hilfe
des alma teleskops ermittelt werden das
ist jetzt verglichen mit anderen jets
anderer galaxien er ein stummel aber
immerhin das röntgenteleskop xmm-newton
konnte die zion offenbaren sie sich
diesen gasstrom anschließt auch hier
überraschende auffälligkeiten die auf
einen jet im herzen der milchstraße
hinweisen konkret konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
wolken aus gas ausfindig machen ihr
glühender heller rand befindet sich
genau in der verlängerung des
aufgespürten gas stroms auch das
hubble-weltraumteleskop konnte seinen
teil dazu beitragen die
infrarotaufnahmen offenbaren dass diese
kegelförmige zone aus verstärkt
angeregten gasen mindestens 35
lichtjahre vom schwarzen loch führen
dazu sagt einer der beteiligten forscher
alex wagner die ausströme sickern aus
verzichten gas scheibe der milchstraße
heraus der jec teilt sich dann von einem
bleistift und strom kranken ähnlich den
tentakeln eines opfers an diesen
tentakeln erstreckt sich eine reihe von
blasen die mindestens 500 lichtjahre
herausragen das spannende dabei genau
diese blasen konnten in früheren
untersuchungen bereits selektiert werden
doch damals konnte man sich nicht
wirklich einen reim auf diese entdeckung
machen erst jetzt wird der zusammenhang
mit der möglichen existenz von jets klar
die aktuelle studie offenbart dass die
jets sich im laufe der zeit stark
verändert haben noch vor wenigen hundert
jahren gab es wohl eine deutlich höhere
aktivität dazu heißt es in der studie
sacchi carius klingt heute nur schwach
aber noch vor wenigen jahrhunderten war
ist 10.000 mal heller doch auch aktuell
produziert unser heimisches schwarzes
loch möglicherweise noch jetzt zwar
schwache aber immerhin und eine
veränderung ist zudem durchaus
vorstellbar dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam schon eine 100-fach
größere helligkeit würde ausreichen um
den jet soweit aufzufüllen dass er auf
ganzer länge ergibt wird wow das bringt
im wahrsten sinne etwas licht ins dunkel
denn auch das rätsel der galaktischen
super blasen hängt womöglich genau damit
zusammen mehr dazu in diesem video
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht ganz einfach mit dem abo button
unter jedem video und kostet hier auf
youtube gar nichts ich freue mich sehr
über jedes neue abo bis dann bleibt dran